Get out your paddles.
"Ooh, you better believe that's a paddlin'."
And celebrate Jingles Day, because this
episode has more twists than a f*cking roller coaster.
Yes, episode 3 of "American Horror Story: 1984"
is jam-packed with cool kills and new theories,
so I'm gonna break down the episode
and what it could mean for the season.
You'll want to stick
around till the very end
for even more tinfoil hat conspiracies about
Montana, Brooke, and the Night Stalker.
So here we go.
The episode begins right where we left off with the Night Stalker trying to break down the door to the infirmary.
We saw him last episode nearing
his way to Ray, Chet, Brooke and Rita,
who have gone in search of the car
keys so they can make their escape.
The Night Stalker smashes his way through
the window, which they quickly board up,
when Ray has quite possibly
the stupidest suggestion ever:
The four of them split up and the
slowest will be the one who gets caught.
"That's ... that's stupid."
But before a plan can be made, the Night Stalker
bursts through the door and Ray gets caught in his way.
Now here is where I caught
something really weird.
This is the shot of Ray right when
the Night Stalker bursts down the door.
Take note of his jacket.
We then cut to the Night
Stalker and then back to Ray,
but look at his jacket now:
covered in blood splatter.
Now, this could a) just be a simple
mistake they made when filming,
or b) if you believe the
theory that they're all actors
or that this is some sort of Groundhog
Day that repeats over and over again,
it could be another subtle hint
that that's what we're watching.
Ray gets the crap slashed out of him and is saved
by Chet, who rams the Night Stalker into the window.
And instead of finishing him off,
they just kind of leave him there.
Meanwhile at the other camp, Montana and
Trevor try to snap Xavier out of his shell shock,
while they believe Mr. Jingles
is trying to make his way in.
Now, there's something interesting here, too. Right before Jingles leaves, there's a sound of a motorcycle.
But we can't be sure if this is from
the two pranksters or someone else.
The pranksters hurl
a flaming bag of crap
But here's yet another weird editing,
and I'm hesitant to say it, mistake.
Check out this shot of the flaming poo
taken from the season to come preview
and compare it to the one
that was shown this episode.
One is clearly wearing a
mask, while the other is not.
Is this just a mistake and they
reshot it or digitally added in a mask?
Who knows, but these little
mistakes are starting to add up.
The fun is short-lived as the two pranksters
are viciously murdered by the real Mr. Jingles.
Apparently, it's customary for local
kids to play pranks during "Jingles Day",
the anniversary of the
Camp Redwood massacre.
Jingles cuts off one of the kid's ears as
Trevor, Montana, and Xavier make a run for it.
Brooke and Rita have split from Chet and Ray when we hear a scream coming from Chet and Ray's direction.
They've fallen into a pit of spikes and Chet
seems to have gotten the worst of the two.
Now, what's interesting about this is that it
couldn't have been Jingles who set up this trap.
He just got to Camp
Redwood a few hours ago,
so someone else must have
riddled these woods with traps.
My best guess is that this was Rita, as we'll
later find out she's in cahoots with Jingles.
Now this is another interesting scene.
Jingle stumbles across one of the pranksters
who we learn was brought in to the
prank because his mother paid the other kids.
He doesn't have glasses, uses an inhaler, has reverence for Jingles, and just wants to be a badass for the night.
Jingles lets him live.
Now, it could be because Jingles feels
sorry for him or sees a bit of himself in this kid.
Either way, it proves that there's
more to Jingles than meets the eye.
He doesn't simply kill
everything that gets in his way.
Ray tries to get the spike out of Chet's shoulder,
but if he does, Chet will likely bleed to death.
Chet thinks it was Jingles who
dug the pit since it's a punji pit,
a trap used by the Viet Cong
during the Vietnam War.
And we know Jingles used to fight Nam.
But if Rita is working with Jingles, it's possible that
she could have learned about these traps through him.
Brooke and Rita are waiting for the others
when Brooke suggests they go and get help.
Rita says,
"And leave everyone here to fend for themselves?
Your friends wouldn't bail on you like that."
Uh, we know one who would.
Rita gives her the keys, and in the first big twist of
the season, she drugs Brooke before she can go,
showing us that she's in league with
Jingles, which we'll get into in a bit.
After all, last episode, we saw her confronted
by him, but we never saw the actual fight.
They were likely planning out the next steps.
We find out a week ago that Rita is actually
renowned psychologist Donna Chambers.
So good, in fact, she was able to get new information out of such killers as Ted Bundy and John Wayne Gacy.
Also interesting to note that John
Carroll Lynch, the man who plays Jingles,
also played Gacy in
season seven's "Cult".
Whereas Hopple believes some people are
simply pure evil, Donna believes otherwise,
and is able to convince
Hopple of letting her interview him.
Donna meets with Jingles and
is able to break through to him.
Everyone has said he's an irredeemable
monster, but Donna believes otherwise.
External events, such as
Vietnam, caused him to go crazy.
If she can pinpoint what made him snap in what he did, she can maybe prevent future killings from happening.
We also learn that Jingles never remembered
killing those kids. That's very important.
And it was actually the doctors
who said he had this psychotic break,
leaving the theory that it was
Margaret who's the real killer still on the table.
Rita's talk about trauma
being a cause for serial killing
could also correlate with characters like Brooke and Xavier, who have had traumatic experiences in the past.
Donna proposes an
absolutely outrageous plan:
She needs to witness
Jingles in his natural habitat,
and helps him break out by
providing him with his bag and knife.
But when Jingles prods her as to
why'd she do this, she simply says,
"I have my reasons."
So don't count out that Donna has an
ulterior motive for this entire operation.
And here we have our first glimpse of the real
nurse Rita, who we saw in the preview video.
Donna is following her as they drive into
Roy's gas station, the same one from episode 1.
Rita suggests they convoy up and
Donna says something very peculiar here.
"If you ask me, all those murders are
because of the availability of pornography,
and the objectification
of women in our culture."
This is the second time she's
mentioned how bad pornography is,
and I can't help but
think how in episode 1,
Margaret ranted about how she
fought alongside Charles Keating,
an anti-pornographer
who took on Larry Flynt.
It makes me wonder if there is a deeper
connection between Margaret and Donna.
And this is exactly what I'd expect a
gas-station washroom to look like.
Rita returns to find Donna missing, so
she heads on over to Camp Redwood
only to find Rita in the back of her car.
We flash forward to find that
Rita isn't really a nurse - shocker -
and that she gave
Brooke horse tranquilizers.
Speaking of people passed out, we have
Chet, who doesn't seem to be doing too well.
Ray thinks this is the perfect
opportunity to get something off his chest,
so he tells him his
traumatic experience.
Remember that trauma has
been a big part of this season.
But how the writers are gonna wrap it
all together thematically remains to be seen.
We learn that Ray left
L.A. because he was in trouble.
During a hazing incident for his fraternity,
Omega Xi, a new recruit, Chan, falls down the stairs
and Ray believes he's dead.
Instead of calling an ambulance and
jeopardizing the future of the fraternity,
Ray takes one for the team
and throws Chan off a cliff.
But Chan isn't dead.
Ray tries to help him,
but Chan rips off his watch.
When Ray found out Chan's car had been
found and his watch would be inside the car,
he knew he had
to get out of the city.
This incident made Ray drop out
of school and get a job at a hospital.
We learned in episode 1
that Ray used to be an orderly,
so it's possible he could have a
connection to Jingles' asylum.
Ray learns that Chet heard his entire story and decides to leave the guy who, moments ago, saved his life.
This is not a great
look for Ray this episode.
Trevor, Montana, and Xavier argue
about saving Margaret and Bertie. After all,
"Chef Bertie is good people."
Hiding in the
boathouse, they find Rita.
Remember, it was Donna who drugged her, not
Jingles, so we can deduce that Donna isn't a murderer.
She's merely setting up things for Jingles to
finish off later, which is exactly what he does.
Again, I could totally be looking too deep into
things, but my eyes were drawn to this locket.
And I'm wondering if it were to be opened, if there would be a picture of her and any of the other characters.
Ray runs into Xavier, Trevor, and Montana
and lies to them about how he lost Chet.
They tell him that Rita isn't the real Rita, and Ray argues with them about going back to save Margaret and Bertie.
Trevor gives him his motorcycle keys and
tells him to go to the call box to call the police.
But now that we know Ray
is likely wanted by the police
and earlier this episode
said every man for himself,
My guess is that he'd
never call the police, anyway.
Montana goes with Ray as well,
and this also makes sense because earlier, she argued against going back to look for Margaret and Bertie.
Jingles is alerted to the
sound of Chet, but it's a fake out.
Xavier and Trevor help him out, and they
learn the truth: that Ray left Chet to die.
Trevor musters his Big Dick Energy and
throws who he thinks is Jingles into the pit.
But it's actually our inhaler guy
we met earlier in the episode.
But what I think is most interesting is the absence of
this shot, which we saw in the season to come trailer.
We have Jingles pouring
gasoline into the pit with Ray.
Now this could mean a few things: a) that
this is something we'll see in the future,
b) it's a total fake out
just to throw us off,
but usually, a show wouldn't go through the lengths of shooting this just for a quick 1-second shot in the trailer.
Or c) that we're going to eventually
deal with multiple timelines,
that we'll come back to Camp Redwood somehow
and the characters will go through the same night
but different things will happen.
Ray and Montana make
a run for the parking lot,
but as soon as they're confronted by the Night Stalker, Ray takes the motorcycle, leaving Montana in the dust.
But he finally gets what's coming to
him as Mr. Jingles decapitates him.
But before he dies, Ray says what I think is
the most important line in the entire episode:
Quote: "Suck a nut, Camp
Redwood. See you in another life."
Now we've already seen one character
have multiple lives: the hitchhiker.
And we previously discussed this
shot of Ray in the pit with Mr. Jingles.
Is it possible this night repeats over and
over like some sort of Groundhog Day?
The end of the episode leaves
us with another huge twist:
that Montana and the
Night Stalker are lovers,
ending with Montana asking
why he hasn't "killed her yet".
This "her" is likely
referring to Brooke.
After all, we already know the
Night Stalker and Brooke have a history.
But the history we've seen is from Brooke's
perspective. What if that perspective isn't reliable?
From this brief interaction, it seems
Montana is the one pulling the strings.
She's the one with the
vendetta against Brooke.
What if there's a more nefarious
side to Brooke we haven't seen?
One of the more curious shots we
saw this season was in episode 1
where Brooke briefly
shows us her jewelry box.
Not only are there a few rings here,
but later that night when the Night Stalker visits
her, the first thing he asked for is her jewelry.
The Night Stalker came into her house with the intention of finding this specific ring at the behest of Montana,
which is the same exact ring we see
in the wedding flashback in episode 2.
This likely means there is some sort of connection between Montana, the ring, and Joseph Cavanaugh.
Perhaps Montana was a jealous ex-lover
or a family member hell-bent on revenge.
We'll need to stay tuned to find out.
This episode was nuts, and as always, I want
to hear your theories in the comments below.
Make sure to give the video a
like and subscribe with the bell on
to get the latest "American
Horror Story" breakdowns.
You can also find me on
Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.